today you will see ai from a different  perspective  the idea of human created objects  coming to life was with us for a very  long time  we will take a look at how life  intersects with technology  learning is crucial for us living  organisms  and it's equally crucial for artificial  intelligence and the dance  symbolizes how artificial intelligence  processes  information and learns in the adaptive  ai  those two pipelines that were separated  come together  and now the learning happens so much  quicker  ai needs to be secure transparent and  non-biased  it cannot discriminate against anyone  the very primary purpose  of artificial intelligence goes back to  its roots  it is to create a mirror for us humans  and the way in which we can see  ourselves better